In this section of our course, we will take a look at all of the workflows that were used for the atomic savage character.
The process of bringing atomic savage to life began with an initial concept.
Then came the question, is it possible to take a stylized character like atomic savage and transform him into a fully functioning metahuman?
And if so, what steps would need to be taken in order to achieve this?
So let's begin by looking at the first step of this character's journey.
The first step was to take the initial concept of this character and have a sculpted version created using ZBrush.
The head and body were then separated.
Using the topology of a metahuman preset, the metahuman head was fitted to the 3D sculpt.
The metahuman identity texture was used to ensure that important edges and loops for the head were respected.
Once the initial fitting was complete, the next step was to generate a metahuman identity.
The 3D head model fitted with metahuman topology was used with a mesh-to-metahuman workflow using the template mesh option to generate the initial metahuman identity.
The template mesh option helped to get the initial geometry and joint positioning closer to the target delta across all the LODs.
However, due to the scale and stylized features of this character, there was still more work to be done.
The next step was to assemble and prepare this character's assets for the final fitting process.
The source assets of the initial metahuman identity were downloaded from the Quixel Bridge standalone application.
Then the LOD0 of the head geometry and the additional assets were refitted vertex by vertex to match precisely with the fitted 3D head mesh while using LOD2 for easier manipulation of polygons.
Once the final fitting process was complete, the next step was to identify the scale and positional measurements for the head that would be applied with DNA calibration.
To identify the scale and positional measurements, in Maya, a locator was used to preserve the existing translation values of the joints.
Once the locator was used to scale, translate, and rotate the metahuman identity, the values from this process could be applied to the metahuman identity with DNA calibration.
To demonstrate the process of using a locator, let's jump into Maya for a moment.
Inside of Maya, I will walk you through the steps of how to use a locator to identify the scale and positional values while preserving the existing translation values of the joints.
Now I have already loaded the DNA file into a new Maya scene and then added the fitted head mesh in here as a reference.
Let me show you what steps I took in order to assemble the scene.
To load the DNA, I executed the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
If I pull up the DNA viewer window, I loaded the DNA file of the initial metahuman identity for atomic savage.
If you wish to go through these steps, you can find the DNA file I am using in the source files folder.
It is located in the Atomic-S DNA folder.
With the DNA loaded, I assembled only the head LOD zero mesh.
In the build options, I enabled the joints and skin clusters, and then I selected process.
And once this was assembled, I added the fitted 3D head model.
Now that I have gone over how I assembled the scene, let's go over how to use a locator.
I am going to go to the head group and collapse it and select spine 4.
Over here on the right, we can see that this has existing values.
To preserve these, we can use a locator.
To do this, I will go to create, then down here, and I will select locator.
In the outliner, I will make the locator a child of the head group, and then make spine 4 a child of the locator.
Now, we can use a locator to scale and translate the identity while preserving the existing translation values of the spine.
I will unhide the fitted head mesh to use this as a reference, and I will select the locator.
Now, I already have the values that are needed, but to demonstrate what this process would look like, I will switch over to wireframe for a moment.
Then over here, for the translation x, I will set this to negative .106.
For the y, I will set this to negative 18.954.
And for the z, I will set this to negative 20.869.
Then for the scaling, I will change all three values to 1.192.
Finally, for the rotate x, I will set this to 5.858.
It takes a little trial and error to figure these values out.
However, once you have the right values, you will notice that this is a very close approximation of the scale and proportions the head will need to have in order to match up with the target head mesh.
Now that we have seen what this process looks like, let's do a quick review of these steps before we move on.
We just saw how we can use a locator to identify the scale and positional values that will need to be applied to the metahuman identity with DNA calibration.
The steps for using a locator are to use the DNA viewer run in Maya script to load the DNA of the metahuman identity.
In the DNA viewer window, assemble the LOD0 head mesh only and enable the joints and skin clusters in the build options.
Once the scene has been assembled, add the fitted head model into the scene for reference.
To create a locator, go to create and select locator.
Make the locator a child of the head group, then make spine 4 a child of the locator, and then use the locator to move and scale the identity in order to find the desired values.
For atomic savage, once these values were identified, the next step was to prepare the body skeleton Maya file that is required for exporting the head LODs as FBX.
The images on this slide show the progression of steps that were taken to prepare the body skeleton Maya file asset.
The first step was to take the original full body rig Maya file from the source assets downloaded from bridge.
From root to spine 4, all of these joints must be perfectly aligned with the head rig.
So for this reason, without touching the bones from spine 4 and above, spine 1, 2, and 3 were slightly adjusted while leaving everything else the same.
Then, using the same workflow for preparing the body skeleton that we covered in our previous course, the arms and legs were removed, and this prepared body skeleton Maya file was ready to be used with DNA calibration.
The final step for preparing the assets that would be used with DNA calibration was to rig the custom metahuman body.
To rig the custom metahuman body, the prepared body skeleton was used as a base for the height.
From there, the joints with the exception of the spine were adjusted to fit the upper portion of the custom body.
Then, the arm and leg joints of the initial metahuman identity skeleton were bound to the skeleton and then adjusted to fit the rest of the body.
We can see in the images on the slide what the skeleton looked like before and after this process.
Now, with all of the assets ready to be used with DNA calibration, the first script that would be used is the modified version of the UnrealFest calibration script.
The modified version of the UnrealFest calibration script scales the head and transfers the details from the fitted geometry to the DNA.
The script scales, translates, and rotates the head using the values that were identified with the locator.
It then updates the neutral head by transferring the details from the fitted geometry assets.
Then it snaps the surface joints to their new positions, which is important especially for those details to be preserved for lower LODs.
And finally, it saves these changes to the DNA file.
In the images from left to right, we see what the initial metahuman identity looked like before DNA calibration and what it looked like after the script was executed.
And all the way on the right is an image of the head LOD0FBX.
Even though the head geometry and additional assets were finalized, the head skeleton and custom body still needed to be aligned, while also avoiding any seam issues that commonly arise from this process.
To achieve this, the custom body integration workflow script was used.
The custom body integration workflow script aligns the skeletons for the head and body.
It saves those changes to the DNA file and exports the head LODs as FBX with material placeholders.
It also paints weights for the neck seam where the head and body connect, eliminating seam issues.
The only other step after using this workflow was to match the normals for the head and body neck seam area.
The images on this slide show the skeleton before and after this script was used.
Now, the final DNA file and the exported head LOD FBX files, along with the custom metahuman body with the adjusted skin weights on the neck seam area, were ready to be brought into Unreal Engine.
All of the finalized assets for the head and body were brought into Unreal Engine and configured.
The head LODs and updated DNA were re-imported, the body skeleton was imported and assigned to the metahuman-based skeleton, and the metahuman blueprint was updated.
The face and body were then tested with animations, and it was during the testing process it became apparent that due to the significant differences in skeleton proportions,
animations would need to be retargeted from the standard metahuman-based skeleton to the custom body one,
and body correctives would be needed to finalize this character's customizations.
When applying animations to the body, due to the significant differences in skeleton proportions, animations had to be retargeted even though the source and target skeletons shared the metahuman-based skeleton.
To correct problematic areas during deformation, the pose driver connect tool set was used to author corrective poses.
A good example of this is demonstrated in the images on the bottom of the slide where we can see what the shoulder and neck region looks like when animations are applied.
Now, we have just seen how atomic savage went from a concept to a fully functioning metahuman, and we touched on the various workflows that were used to finalize this character.
In the next portion of our course, we delve deeper into the DNA calibration workflows that were used with this character.